by 2025 almost half of all jobs in
Europe will need highly-skilled workers
in the future people will also need some
level of digital skills for 90% of all
jobs the lack of basic skills in Europe
is striking one in five Europeans that
struggle to read and write one in four
Europeans have poor numeracy skills and
40% have no digital skills and one in
five Europeans at lack a high school
qualification the skills mismatch shows
that Europe isn't making the best of
people's talents 40 percent of European
employers cannot find employees with the
right skills and 30 percent of people
working jobs that don't match their
qualification globalization and
technology is fast changing the way
people learn new skills but their
qualifications lag behind the new skills
agenda for Europe will help equip
Europeans with more and better skills by
investing in people's basic and higher
skills by better connecting the world of
business and education by recognizing
skills learned outside of school Europe
making the best of people's talents
you